So, here's how delta debugging works: first, we split the input
into n subsets where initially n has a value of 2. Second, if removing
any of these subsets fails, proceed with this very subset.
This is what we have for our input.
We split the input into initially two subsets,
and if any of these subsets fails, as in here, we proceed with this very subset,
otherwise, we simply go and increase the granularity,
that is, we double the number of subsets
and we go again to step one.
Let's try this out on our input over here.
So, at this point we already tried out removing the second half of the input
and removing the first half of the input.
Neither removal of these subsets would fail,
so now we have to increase the granularity by coming up with now four subsets.
This is a 10-character input,
so each of our subsets will have between two and three characters.
For a change, let's try removing the first two characters.
Well, no select tag, no failure.
We put them back and remove the three characters.
Still no failure, which gets us an "s ct" tag. No failure.
Now, again we remove the next three characters--ct and the greater tag.
No select tag, no failure.
Now we remove the last two characters.
At this point, we have the select tag by itself,
and again we have a failure.
What should we do in this case?
Should we now go and start again with two subsets,
that is, setting n to 2
or should we go and set n to the number of subsets we had before
minus 1 because there's 1 less?
Experiments show that it's best to stick with a granularity you once have achieved,
because then you won't have to track back through all the levels of granularity you already have seen.
So, we set n to n-1, which means that in our case we would have three subsets.
However, we don't want n to be come less than 2,
because otherwise we'd just have one subset.
So, we set n to the maximum of n -1 and 2 such that n can never fall below 2.
So, at this point, our input is just the select tag.
It fails, and the number of subsets is 3.
What is it that delta debugging would do next
according to this description of the algorithm?
And what is the next test that delta debugging has to conduct?
Is this the select tag as a whole?
Is this the select tag with the second half removed?
Is this the select tag with the first 3rd removed?
Or is this just ct> that is the last 3rd of the input? Over to you.